arno only has 1 party
with which we can save the Netherlands 1 little bit
desforums the people
do not know what is going on in the entire agricultural sector
people want to work harder and harder for the head
above water
that will eventually no longer work
it's 1 line on 1 line on all fronts
people just have to open their eyes
my eyes there is only 1 party
with which we can save the Netherlands 1 little bit
des forums but not with bbp
because they have just proven in the States that they
in my eyes don't have much of pastry
because it might be
for some policies slightly postponed for 2 years
but that is of no use to us
just need nitrogen from the table
this is just pure and nonsense
there is absolutely nothing wrong when I am in the Betuwe
look it is
everything is still in perfect condition
locks have never been so clean
there are fish in it
everything is just fine in the whole biodiversity
choke on the beasts
the models that
models that I just look around me
and to walk to all kinds of animals in De Boomgaard
and also measurements
done well
prove the measurements
see how many hares are walking
it is unimaginable
yes it is it is huge what flies and walks
look around my eyes and then I said dude
there is nothing wrong at all